Felicity Huffman woke up this morning
for the first time as a prison inmate
sure when the way she wanted to start
her day and we have exclusive new
insight into Felicity's life in lockup
the Emmy winner now known as inmate
number 7 7 8 0 6 - 1 1 - had a 5:00 a.m.
wake-up call
Felicity's allowed to shower once a day
and shares a room and open toilet with
three other inmates but what's it really
like inside Felicity's low security
prison it's no picnic
Petey spoke today with Amy povo she
served nine years in the Dublin
California facility the prison's been
called Club fed in the past but Amy
doesn't like that
I can't people you are inspected nude in
addition to that strip search inmates
are generally fingerprinted on day one
and there's the food on the lunch menu
today a hamburger with a choice of tater
tots or baked potato one of the things
that gets old is the food to this day I
can't really eat oatmeal felicity is
expected to be released a week from
Sunday
you